posting all of us it's really a great
pleasure to be here
do not the kingdom wall so nettles first
home so it is fitting that we meet here
to mark the 70th anniversary of our
alliance to celebrate our success and to
ensure our lines remains fit for the
future NATO is the most successful
alliance in history because we have
changed as the world has changed and in
the last few years we have implemented
the biggest increase of our collective
defence in a generation we have stepped
up in the fight against terrorism and we
are investing more in our defense since
2016 European allies and Canada have
added 130 billion dollars to their
defence budgets this is unprecedented
it is making NATO stronger NATO remains
the only platform where North America
and Europe discuss the side and take
actions together every day to protect
almost 1 billion people so whatever our
differences we will continue to unite
around our core tasks to defend one
another all for one and one for all and
now I invite our host prime minister
Johnston to take the floor so Boris each
other for thank you very much yes and
I'm delighted to welcome everybody here
to the United Kingdom to celebrate the
70th anniversary of NATO and as you say
yes I do feel that our alliance is
coming home because Britain was a
founding member of NATO and it was here
that NATO opened its first headquarters
of course in Belgrave square shortly
actually before moving to Paris as I'm
sure colleagues will recall 70 years on
we are rock solid in our commitment to
NATO and to the giant shield of
solidarity that now protects 29
countries and nearly a billion people
the fact that we live in peace today
demonstrates the power as Johnson the UK
Prime Minister there who's chairing the
gathering in what for just north of
London saying welcome to everyone
reminding the world and indeed all the
NATO members that are there not just
presidents prime ministers but also
their ancillary staff their civil
servants their foreign ministers people
like Dominic Raab the UK foreign
minister will be there Mike Pompeo the
US Secretary of State he will be in
orbit as well yeah in Stoltenberg doing
two things very clearly one referring to
what's called the four musketeers clause
which is one for all all for one that's
what NATO is all about and also let's
talk to James BAE's a diplomatic editor
about this one specifically James saying
straight up first line there from Yen
Stoltenberg we are adding more money to
our budget so clearly signaling to
Donald Trump look you know you've been
nagging nagging us about this for a few
years now and we're doing it yes I think
trying to show Donald Trump that things
are changing and certainly when he spoke
with President Trump when they were
photographed together and spoke together
24 hours ago crediting President Trump
with changing things but the Trump
factor is an important factor in all of
this it's worth noting that this is the
70th year of NATO and they're having
this big gathering in the UK because the
first temporary headquarters of NATO was
in London and actually the actual
signing of the treaty which has that
article 5 which says that any one NATO
member under attack all the others will
support that member that treaty was
actually signed in Washington but the
actual moment of remembering that treaty
signing which I attended in Washington
in the summer was pretty low-key only
foreign ministers why did they not have
this big summit in the summer in
Washington because of President Trump
they really feared the unpredictability
of him hosting a gathering like this and
that remains I think particularly after
the events of summer 2018 when it looked
like in a summit in NATO that President
Trump was about to pull out of the
alliance and really fraught discussions
during that summit President Trump I
think remains
one of the most unpredictable elements
of of this alliance but remember also
what president McConnell said in that
interview in which he said that
strategically NATO was brain dead he
doubted whether that article 5 whether
France necessarily would act under that
article 5 so this basic loyalty that is
that NATO is supposed to be about this
alliance and this treaty is supposed to
be about I think it's an in some doubt
right now James for the moment thank you
very much and we'll of course keep you
across all the developments coming to us
from that NATO 70th birthday gathering
in London hasn't when we can